the stars dropped all kinds of delicious
red carpet fashion facts and emmy looks
to be loved
[Applause]
if you're gonna be unbasically black
your hair must be
stella
girl you gotta serve if you can still
serve
how many fittings uh we had like three
including two today
cinderella has arrived
sweatier ella
is it a little sweaty under there it's a
little bit moist so i'm not gonna lie
actually hannah was hiding sparkly
sneakers under that gown other emmy
style secrets euphoria's sydney
sweeney's glam squad was still cutting
and stitching the details of her oscar
de laurenta gown just minutes before she
hit the gold carpet
tell me what your stylist did to find
this dress lots of tape she was a bit of
a last minute swat swap-a-roos wow the
backup dress for the win what's the
dress this is sergio headset
lizzo had a stylist dedicated to
carrying her near 10-foot train but she
called out jason bateman for this pretty
unavoidable fashion oops
lizzo's john batista volley gown was
actually ripped straight from the runway
same goes for laura linney christina
ricci kerry washington and amanda
seifried of course it is it's heavy it's
like armor it's like it's like i'm like
a knight
gonna present and hang out and then you
know go home and put some pajamas on
without the shades
blinding oh we see you andrew garfield
serving up looks men in white was
totally a thing first time winner gerard
carmichael went shirtless under his
giant fur you know what the puff daddy
wore this fur in the music video
if i had lost
and i'm wearing this
like you kind of look silly
but when you win like all of a sudden
like oh wearing foxes and crazy
backstage we spoke with another big
winner john oliver who took home his
seventh consecutive outstanding variety
talk series emmy for last week tonight
and had a fanboy moment on stage when i
saw steve martin and minus short walking
out but they're not presenting our
category
that seems like
they are slumming it in an absolutely
ludicrous way john you know i have to
have asked about world events because
you're here yes huge change going on in
england right now the whole thing is
going to be a huge adjustment i think
the queen was universally beloved and i
think you could the nicest thing you
could say about
prince charles or king charles now is
that he is less so right so uh i think
he's probably got a monumental pr
exercise over in england our katy nickel
is outside buckingham palace where the
queen's coffin now rests
yes the queen's coffin made its journey
from scotland to england this afternoon
king charles and queen consort camilla
were joined by william and kate harry
and megan and the queen's other children
and grandchildren to witness the
coffin's arrival here at buckingham
palace as for harry not being permitted
to wear his military uniform a sussex
spokesperson says his decade of military
service is not determined by the uniform
he wears and we respectfully ask that
focus remain on the life and legacy of
her majesty queen elizabeth ii
big congrats to the gina davis institute
of gender and media who took home this
year's governor's award we've made a
great deal of progress but
still there's more work to do of course
backstage gina spoke to me about another
goal reuniting with thelma and louise
co-star susan sarandon can we see more
from you guys we remain very very good
friends so
yeah you know we're just looking for
something good to come along
you